ERIC: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
LAURA.
LAURA: WE HAVE MORE NOW WITH
DOCTOR MARK SIEGEL, FOX NEWS
MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR.
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK, COVERED, THE
POLITICS AND POWER OF SCIENCE.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU AND GET
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
WE’VE HEARD ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY THE NEW STRAIN IS SO
CONCERNING IS HOW FAST IT CAN
SPREAD.
HOW EXACTLY IS THIS DIFFERENT?
AND WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT IT?
>> PEOPLE OUT THERE NEED TO BE
REASSURED BY THE FACT THAT
VIRUSES, ESPECIALLY THIS KIND OF
RNA VIRUS ARE ALWAYS CHANGING
AND MUTATING.
WHEN WE HEAR THE WORD MUTATION,
WE GET SCARED AND WORRIED BUT
THE TRUTH IS, IT’S HAPPENING ALL
THE TIME.
THIS PARTICULAR STRAIN WHICH HAS
MULTIPLE CHANGES HAS BEEN AROUND
SINCE OCTOBER IN THE UK AND HAS
SPREAD TO NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES.
IT’S BEEN IN THE NETHERLANDS,
DENMARK AND EVEN AS FAR AS ITALY
AND AUSTRALIA BUT IT’S PROBABLY
HERE IN THE U.S.
SCHOOL OF HYGIENE AND TROPICAL
MEDICINE SAYS IT’S ABOUT 56%
MORE CONTAGIOUS BUT THAT’S A
MATHEMATICAL MODEL.
WE DON’T KNOW FOR SURE.
ONE THING WE DON’T DO ENOUGH OF
HIS LABORATORY TESTING TO SEE
ABOUT DIFFERENT STRAINS SO
THAT’S WHY I’M GLAD TO SEE L.A.
COUNTY DOING THAT.
LAURA: I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
YOUR ASSESSMENT ON L.A. COUNTY
BECAUSE CHRISTINA COLEMAN REPORT
SHOWED ALARMING STATS AS WE LOOK
AT THE TALLY, STATE OFFICIALS
THERE SAYING THE RATE OF
ACCELERATION HAS GONE BEYOND ANY
MODEL AND EXPECTATION THEY’VE
HAD.
COULD IT BE A DOUBLE WHAMMY OF
COVID AND THE NEW STRAIN?
WHAT YOU THINK IS HAPPENING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT IS
POSSIBLE.
13600 NEW CASES THURSDAY ALONE
WHICH IS EXORBITANT.
SO FAR, GENETIC TESTING HAS NOT
SHOWN IT’S THAT STRAIN.
IF IT WERE, I WANT TO REASSURE
PEOPLE THAT AS THESE VIRUSES
MUTATE OVER THE COURSE OF A
PANDEMIC, THEY TEND TO BE MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO SURVIVE.
IF A PERSON DIES, IT DOESN’T
SPREAD SO THEY TEND TO BE MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE BUT ALSO LESS
VIRULENT MEANING THEY ARE NOT AS
DEADLY AND DON’T BECAUSE AS MUCH
SEVERE DISEASE AND THOSE NO
EVIDENCE WITH THIS LONDON
STRENGTH WHATSOEVER THAT IT
MAKES PEOPLE SICK OR IN ITS TRUE
OF THE VACCINE.
IT TENDS TO BE COVERED BY THESE
VACCINES.
LAURA: WHAT ARE WE CALLING IT?
I READ BE 117 AND AS YOU
MENTIONED, IT HAS MUTATIONS THAT
ARE DIFFERENT BUT MAYBE WE
SHOULD NOT BE ALARMED BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED ANYWAY
BUT WHAT ARE WE CALLING IT SO
WHEN WE READ IT WE KNOW WHAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT CAN -- IS A
VACCINE WE ARE HEARING ABOUT
YOUR PFIZER AND MODERNA, WILL IT
PROTECT AGAINST THE?
>> THE NAME YOU GAVE IS RIGHT,
THE 117, IS ABOUT 20 MUTATIONS
OCCURRING BUT SOME ARE THE
SURFACE PROTEINS WE ARE LOOKING
AT, THE PROTEIN WE TARGET THE
VACCINE FOR BUT VACCINE
SCIENTISTS ARE SAYING THE SAME
THING, IT WOULD TAKE SO MANY
CHANGES TO THE SERVICE PROTEIN
BEFORE IT WOULD AFFECT THE
VACCINE.
THE PFIZER AND MODERNA VACCINES
SPECIFICALLY, THE ONES THAT ARE
OUT NOW, THEY GO FOR MULTIPLE
TARGETS ON THAT CAUSING AND
ENORMOUS ROBUST RESPONSE.
ALMOST ZERO CHANCE IT WOULD HAVE
VACCINE COVERAGE AT THE TIME.